those women are a bit too lazy to do it
they don't want it I don't I don't know
what's going on with you or where you're
coming from or where this sou m is
coming from but I
would great women are lazy men are
better you have you need to if we look
at like um the outcomes like there's
nothing sness thing you know I'm a
hardworking woman but it's like when I
when I look around and see our women
willing to do the hardest jobs in societ
think do I think you're I think you're
struggling with something very deep and
profound and I recommend you a really
good therapist no that they make you
crazy you met
therapist I'm not sure you're in the
best position to be judging
that very nice to meet you